Mike Webb is running
for congress
in Virginia's eighth district.
He recently posted a screenshot
of his desktop
to his Facebook page.
Oh, look,
he's got a lot of tabs open.
Clearly, he's a busy guy.
Quick poll-- anyone
not know where this is going?
Uh, Jack,
activate thermal porn scan.
-Beep.
-(alarm sounding)
-Oh, no.
-FEMALE VOICE: Porn detected.
-Oh, no!
-Porn detected. Porn detected.
-(Hardwick whimpering)
-Porn detected.
-(yelling)
(applause and cheering)
We have porn tabs!
So...
in addition to a Yahoo search
and his AT&T bill right here,
Mr. Webb was also
very interested in,
"Layla Rivera Tight Booty"
and "Ivone Sexy Amateur."
So he's into fitness and
entrepreneurs. That's fantastic.
-(applause and cheering)
-Now...
He's a politician.
Naturally,
he had a great explanation
for the screen grab faux pas.
He was just testing for viruses!
(laughter)
Is what he was doing.
He had the porn sites open
so he could scan for viruses!
(laughter, whooping,
clapping)
Maybe he was jerking it
to his AT&T bill. I don't know.
"Oh, overages, yeah.
Roll-over minutes."
-I don't know.
-(laughter)
I personally would ra...
I'm, like, why...? Why in this
day and age do we feel like
we need to hide this
from people? Like, why...?
You know what? Why doesn't
he just come out and go,
"Yeah, I was cranking it
to porn, you know?
"I want to do
a little genetic re...
"I want to do a little
genetic redistricting.
What's the problem?"
-(applause) -Do you think anyone
would fault him for that?
No one would fault him for that.
I mean,
these are not insane categories.
It's not crazy.
So I don't understand...
Look, any candidate
who embraces his love
of the pornographic arts
would thrive
in today's political landscape.
They'd be like, "Wow.
What a breath of fresh air,"
based on what's going on
in the election.